The joe rogan experience.
So when,
when I worked for Jamison,
I worked for James from,
for two years.
Did the Jamison tore me.
Billy Gardell,
Steve Byrne,
uh,
Michael Loftus,
Nick Griffin and Danny Bevins and you,
they sent cases at Jamison to your house every fucking month they sent cases of
pace is of Jamison.
Nug Spence,
how they expect you to drink it all.
And,
and know when you got to a show,
Jamison waiting in the green room and the rule was you had to drink at Jamison
onstage.
You had to mention how good your Jamison was,
but putting on a show like take a step like,
damn,
that's good fucking Jamison.
Like,
and you had to like,
hey everyone today,
like you had to be pro Jamison.
I got no problem with that because Jameson is pretty God damn good.
It's fucking awesome.
Good Shannon,
we get done the tour.
You ready for this?
They buy us each of them acre of land in,
in fucking,
in Ireland on a river.
All of us right next to each other.
We get a fucking Acre land,
a deed and a picture.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Fucking Jamison was,
you got to build a house in Ireland.
Now you can't build,
you can't build on it.
Can't build on it and it's fucking pointless.
But can you camp on it?
You could camp on it.
They can't take him Billy garden permanent.
Can you have a permanent tent?
Yeah,
but me and a bunch of pikeys ob fucking t w o pikeys.
Yeah Dude,
I've been obsessing about watching these Irish travelers fights.
Can we,
some of the uncles,
oh my God,
they have some of the best fights,
dude.
You got to Brian,
you got to look this up.
They're boring as shit.
I mean most of these guys,
but they're tough guys and everything.
But there's a different style of fighting when you fight bare knuckle and
literally they stand there and volunteer themselves in the face.
It's not like a street fight like you've seen in the states have used that once.
They challenge each other when they challenge each other.
How,
I'll tell you that Johnny.
Johnny Mac.
Yeah.
You're good for nothing.
That's how you are gonna happen and yeah,
cause I thought Boston's Heidi of hall.
I'll tell you,
I don't know.
I'll fight cha anytime before Christmas.
Any.
I thought,
goodness me,
there's a beauty.
I mean,
there's a video of of a pikey driving to a street.
They said,
well,
meet what?
Be a according to the click to flies.
It uploads it.
And whoever knows that one between me cause I,
I tweeted it a while ago.
It's really hilarious,
but I can't find it in my Twitter while the show is going on.
But I want to play it because it's so,
it's so ridiculous to see something really disturbing Irish travelers.
Then there,
there were talking shit before street fight.
It's even better than the actual
most disturbing pikey video on there is most disturbing one.
Every week someone's listening that knows exactly what I'm talking about at.
Please tweet it to Joe and me and Brian,
it is pikey gets what he deserves and it's a bunch of a British school,
kids in a park having beers,
snorting coke,
smoking weed,
and a pike,
you will comes up and he won.
But it's all done post.
It's a,
it's a recount of the British kid going.
So a little pikey comes up and he wants to little drink.
He wants a thing.
I didn't do this and that.
Well,
we tell them it's cocaine,
but guess who just got a nose full of k,
a special k and they cut in the pike.
He is fucking seizuring on the ground.
It's bulky.
Sketchy.
Breaks your heart because you go,
that guy's helpless.
He's in a k hole right now.
He's not coming out anytime soon and it's all,
it's if you've,
if you type in Brian of you typing pikey gets what he deserves,
park or something like that,
you'll see it and it fucking,
you just go,
oh,
that shit happens.
That fucking happens.
That does happen.
But manuals pikey fights were gripe.
Fucking was obsessed with those for a while.
Here's one of them.
Brian,
can you find this?
I'll tell you the name.
Tell me when you're ready.
All right.
Big Joe's Davey Joyce.
Reply to Simon.
Oh.
Oh,
shut the fuck on.
I'll wait.
Is this a Vlog?
No,
it's,
they say it one more time.
Okay.
Big Joe's just type in big Joe's Davey Joyce reply.
Just type in that big Joe's Joe s,
David d a v Y Joyce.
J.
O.
Y C E reply.
Yeah.
Hello?
Say me.
No squeak.
Cause I call you tonight.
You're gonna kill it.
Hold on.
Stop.
Brian,
you got two things playing at the same time.
It's two things.
Playing his him and then there's something about going on in the background.
Did you hear it?
Oh,
it's a local thug who gets what he deserves.
It was the,
it was the thing that Burt told him.
Oh I'm sorry.
Baffled.
I couldn't hear how horrible.
Just want to hear this guy's blog.
Yeah,
he's what it,
this is what's going on here.
There's a guy who was talking shit about him online site.
I don't fight Ya.
If I change any time,
Jen,
now can I say this guy his back to reply to them anytime between now and
Christmas.
How does it here it goes to present.
Hey,
same.
You'll be stepping into killed at a hospital if be putting all of your pet and
just say,
Yo,
I can I finish with if you come out and fight bigger.
Yeah.
Dot.
The squeakiness unfold.
How about and fight those type name ready by?
We cannot do that same.
We all play with the hands.
Y'All are wanting to play with your hands.
Come up though.
I'll come out and play with time.
We cannot do that.
Fight.
What's being done.
Yeah.
Dorothy squeaky could up
right?
Always take their shirts off.
We get seriously even when they have terrible chess.
Do you want me to slow it down a little?
No,
it's beautiful.
These are not placing.
We're on the right top of the site that they're living in,
but a capable of Fred or we'll just stay out of it.
They do like places that make an ideal.
This sign you caught up but all you need the rat poison would be demand dinner.
Hope you had a bed.
Oh Darling,
you're squeaky innocent.
Work done.
Yeah.
Hey,
this look Nigga don't syndrome in the tip payment.
You look like a,
Oh,
here are the shirts off.
Why do you like that?
You have come on the trip on your body like that guy's getting aroused
isn't dependent as I see the temps and England and this one takes it back though
with fucking fine.
Bye fucker know [inaudible] everyone had governor.
It was good for this.
Why am I buying the Phytel Simon Dublin
is
my first time to show you one tip brushed me at home and him this way.
Yeah,
he did give you a brand damage.
Sweatiness different lift your head never had that side of the dodge by the
Denison.
Yeah.
Dot.
They could for Dutton bastard.
Does he good for nothing.
So you mean if I was,
I can start out are the best.
But the funny show I seen the type of stairs,
the doctor,
he took his pastors go,
you're telling me I'm fine.
Hi.
Okay.
Your worst nightmare.
I'm your worst nightmare
Anthony.
We call you shake the pocket
for a whole two weeks.
Give me all.
But it was finished.
We up in Dublin.
You want to let the trailer,
you were shaking it up for two weeks.
But Simon,
I am crystal,
you know,
officially shy,
hinder booking as well.
I'm calling you to Hawaii.
I,
I all going to be shutting the fuck over 12 weeks as well.
So that's what your world is shaking the vocal,
what do we call the shy?
Hindered.
Can we,
can we please do this?
Okay.
Listen please.
Anyone.
Everyone right now,
uh,
do or their response video to this guy go,
I don't know shiny,
but I know you and I'll fucking kick your ass.
Who the fuck do you think you are?
Like do your American take your shirt off.
Let's see how good they can get.
Oh fuck.
I want to do one tonight.
I want to do with the second we get done.
Brian,
get a camera.
I'm doing to reply to that guy.
What's his name?
Big John.
And I'm going to be dead.
Fucking serious.
So big John sees and either,
you know,
he doesn't get irony.
He's gonna be sitting in this trailer going,
who the fuck on is the slow modem that he's got to use these?
Use these.
John Haley was going to use these shirts coming off
the shirt coming off as a strange move.
Cause especially I don't give a fuck move.
It's like that white rapper that I was talking about earlier,
who is,
he takes his shirt off.
It's like,
Oh,
do Kumu.
Fuck the guy with Birdman.
I don't know,
but he didn't give a fuck.
His whole thing was that he didn't give a fuck.
Well,
this guy basically is doing the same thing.
He doesn't give a fuck.
It takes his shirt off.
He knows he's fat and love it.
He knows he's not pressing shirt comes off.
That's when the fuck,
what's up Phil Baroni under there.
You know,
that's not a,
that's not a young Randy coture.
Come on,
son.
What are you looking at for now,
Brian?
You're looking at Irish funerals,
the bagpipes and buttholes.
It's like buffaloes.
Put the bag pipes
grown man.
Ladies and gentlemen.